In this segment we provide a
high level introduction into
the conceptual framework of
classical statistics.
In order to get there, it is
better to start from what we
already know and then
make a comparison.
We already know how to make
inferences by just using the
Bayes rule.
In this setting, we have an
unknown quantity, theta, which
we model as a random variable.
And so in particular, it's going
to have a probability
distribution.
And then we make some
observations.
And those observations are
modeled as random variables.
And typically we are given the
conditional distribution of
the observations given
the unknown variable.
So these two distributions are
the starting points, and then
we do some calculations.
And we use the Bayes rule.
And we find the posterior
distribution of theta given
the observations.
And this tells us all that there
is to know about the
unknown quantity, theta,
given the observations
that we have made.
What is important in this
framework is that theta is
treated as a random variable.
And so it has a distribution
of its own.
And that's our starting point.
These are our prior beliefs
about theta before we obtain
any observations.
However, one can think of
situations where theta maybe
cannot be modeled as
a random variable.
Suppose that theta is at some
universal, physical constant.
For example the mass
of the electron.
Does it make sense to think of
that quantity as random?
And how do we come up with a
probability distribution for
that quantity?
One can argue that in certain
situations one should not
think of unknown quantities as
being random, but rather they
are just unknown constants.
They are absolute constants.
It just happens that we do
not know their value.
Or there may be other situations
in which even
though we may think that there
is something random that
determines theta, we are
reluctant to postulate any
prior distribution.
We do not want to impose
any biases.
And that leads us to the classic
statistical framework
in which unknown quantities are
treated as constants, not
as random variables.
Pictorially the setting
is as follows.
There's an unknown quantity
that we wish to estimate.
And we make some observations,
X. Those
observations are random.
And they're drawn according to
a probability distribution.
And that probability
distribution depends, or
rather is affected, by that
unknown quantity.
So for example, for one value of
theta, the distribution of
the X's might be this one.
And for another value of theta,
the distribution of the
X's could be a different one.
And we're trying to guess
what theta is.
Which in some ways is the
question, do my data come from
this distribution or do they
come from that distribution?
In order to make a choice of
theta, what we do is we take
the data and we process them.
And after we process them, we
come up with our estimate--
or rather estimator.
What is the estimator?
We take the data, and
we calculate a
function of the data.
That's what it means to
process the data.
And that function is
our theta hat.
Now this function, our data
processing mechanism, is what
we can call an estimator.
But quite often, or usually,
we also use the same
terminology to call theta
hat itself an estimator.
Now notice that theta hat is
a function of the random
variable X. So theta hat is
actually a random variable.
And that's why we denote it
with an uppercase theta.
On the other hand, after you
obtain some concrete data,
little x, which are the realized
values of the random
variable capital X. Then we can
apply your estimator to
that particular input, and we
compute a specific value--
call it theta hat lower case.
And that quantity we
call an estimate.
So this is a useful
distinction.
Always, with random variables,
we want to distinguish between
the random variable itself
indicated by uppercase letters
and the values of the random
variable, which are indicated
with lower case letters.
Similarly, the estimator
is a random variable.
It's essentially a description
of how we generate estimates.
Whereas the realized value,
once we have some specific
observations at hand--
that's what we call
an estimate.
Now let me continue with
a few comments.
The picture, or the setting,
that I have here suggests that
X is just one variable and
theta is one variable.
But we can have the same
framework, even if X and theta
are multi-dimensional.
For example, X might consist of
several random variables.
And theta may be a parameter
that consists of multiple
components.
Now you may notice that this
notation that we're using here
is a little different from our
traditional notation which was
of this form.
In what ways is it different?
The main difference is
that here, theta is
not a random variable.
Theta is just a parameter.
So what we're dealing with,
here, is just an ordinary--
not a conditional
distribution.
It's an ordinary distribution
that happens to involve,
inside its description,
some parameters theta.
Just to emphasize the point that
these are not conditional
probabilities, because theta is
not a random variable, we
use a semicolon instead
of using a bar.
And since theta is not a random
variable, we do not
include it in the subscript down
here when we talk about
the classical setting.
The best way to think of the
situation mathematically is
that we're essentially dealing
with multiple candidate
models, as in this picture.
This could be one possible
model of X. This could be
another possible model of X.
We have one such model for
each possible value of theta.
And if, for example, I were to
get data points that sit down
here, then a reasonable way to
make an inference could be to
say, these data are extremely
unlikely to have been
generated according
to this model.
This data are quite likely
to have been
generated by this model.
So I'm going to pick this
particular model.
So even though we're not
treating theta as a random
variable, and we do not have the
Bayes rule in our hands--
we can still see, at least from
this trivial example,
that there should be a
reasonable way of making
inferences.
And let me close with some
comments on the different
types of problems that we may
encounter in classical
statistics.
One class of problems are
so-called hypothesis testing
problems in which we're asked
to choose between two
candidate models.
So the unknown parameter, as in
this example, can take one
of two values.
So think of a machine
that produces coins.
And coins are either
fair or they have a
very specific bias.
You want to flip the coin, maybe
multiple times, and then
decide whether you're dealing
with a coin of this
type or of that type.
There's another type of
hypothesis testing problems
which is a little more
complicated, for
example this one.
We have one hypothesis which
says that my coin is fair,
versus an alternative
hypothesis in
which my coin is unfair.
But notice that this hypothesis
actually includes
many possible scenarios.
There are many possible values
of theta under which this
hypothesis would be true.
We will not deal with problems
of this kind in this segment,
or in this lecture sequence.
Instead we will focus
exclusively
on estimation problems.
In estimation problems, the
unknown parameter, theta, is
either continuous or can take
one of many, many values.
What we want to do is to
design an estimator--
a way of processing the data--
that comes up with estimates
that are good.
What does it mean that
an estimate is good?
An estimate would be good if
the resulting value of the
estimation error--
that is the difference between
the estimated value and the
true value--
if that difference is small.
You want to keep
that difference
small in some sense.
Well one may need a criterion of
what it means to be small.
And whether we want this in
expectation, or with high
probability, and so on.
This statement, to keep the
estimation error small, can be
interpreted in various ways.
And because of that reason,
there's no single approach to
the problem of designing
a good estimator.
And this is something that
happens more generally in
classical statistics.
Typically problems do not admit
a single best approach.
They do not admit
unique answers.
Reasonable people can come up
with different methodologies
for approaching the
same problem.
And there is a little bit
of an element of an
art involved here.
In general, one wants to come
up with reasonable methods
that will have good
properties.
And we will see some examples
of what this may mean.
But again, I'm emphasizing
that there is
no single best method.
So whereas the Bayes rule is a
completely unambiguous way for
making inferences, here, in
the context of classical
statistics, there will be some
freedom as to what approaches
one might take.